Is there a downside to the microkernel based approach? Well, there is. There is
a potential for performance loss. Now consider
this monolithic structure. Let's say this application
makes a call to the file system to open up a file. The application slips
through this red line into the hardware address space of the operating system.
It runs in privileged mode because the
operating system may have to do certain things
that are privileged, and therefore, the hardware
architecture of the CPU usually allows a privileged
mode for execution of the operating system code. So now the app is now inside
the operating system in a privileged mode
with one instruction usually, called a trap instruction.
For example, a system call results in a trap into the operating system. And once
inside the operating system, all the work that
needs to be done in order to satisfy
the file system call that the app
made. For instance, contacting the storage manager, contacting
the memory manager and so on. All off
that, are available as components within this blob.
Which means that those components can be accessed at the speed of normal
procedure call in order to handle the original request from this application.
On the other hand, if you look at a microkernel based
structure, the application has to make an IPC call in
order to contact the service, which is, in this case, a file system
service let's say. Which means that the application has
to go through the microkernel, making the IPC call. Going
up to the file system and the file system does
the work, makes another IPC call in order to deliver
the results of that system service back up to
the application. So the minimum traversal so that you can
see is going from the application of the microkernel, microkernel
to the file system, and back into the microkernel and
back up to the application. Potentially, there may
be many more calls that may happen among servers
that are sitting above the microkernel. Because the file
system may have to contact the storage manager and
the file system may have to contact the
memory manager. All of those are server processes living
above the microkernel and all of them require IPC
for talking to one another. So what that means
is that with this structure, there is a potential
that we may have to switch between the address
spaces of the application and many services that are
living on top of the microkernel. Whereas in the
case of the monolithic structure that I showed you
here, there is only two address space switches, one
to go from the application into the operating system,
and the other to return back to the application.
Whereas in a microkernel based design, there could potentially
be several address space switches depending on the number of
servers that need to be contacted in order to satisfy
one system call that may be emanating from the application.